welcome back to sky news live from the  mail we just have some breaking news for  you concerning the queen we know that  she is picking and choosing what  celebration she can go to this weekend  to mark her platinum jubilee and  buckingham palace have just informed us  that she will not be going to the edson  derby races tomorrow it's a favor on her  calendar she missed the thanksgiving  service uh at some point she wasn't able  to make that but we are told that she  will be watching it on television from  windsor castle instead so that is the  queen not going to the epsom derby  tomorrow she will again be represented  by other members of the royal family